the most profound things that has
impacted me in the last year was you
said I hire top down yeah what does that
mean most people try to hire from the
bottom up you'll be like oh well I need
an admin I need a sales guy I need a
marketing person and to me that's the
wrong approach because you're still the
person running the company You're Still
The One having to make these five hires
what I do before I start any company is
I hire the top guy the COO because I'm
expecting them to hire all these other
people for me and I only want to talk to
one person if I hire the right person
once they're going to hire everyone else
and like that's a huge return